[Music]
quite the disruptive new year's eve
after drag racing in one northwest
valley neighborhood thanks for joining
us tonight at 6 30 i'm sasha loftis it's
another complaint after months of
similar activity all over the northwest
valley and in north las vegas this most
recent situation happened last night
near grand canyon and gown road madison
kimbrough has more with what one woman
describes as a terrifying ordeal
street racing in the northwest valley is
nothing new but according to neighbors
last night on new year's eve it took it
to a whole new level
hundreds of people swarmed the area of
grand canyon and gown as cars zipped up
and down racing at all hours of the
night new year's eve remnants of
headlights and other car parts could be
found on the street after the racing
took place carrie who lives right around
the corner says this type of racing
occurs almost every weekend but last
night was especially alarming since
there were so many people out standing
around in crowds neighbors say they
called police but officers never showed
when kerry made the report she was told
to get their license plates but says it
was hard to do so in fear of getting hit
or threatened
it was terrifying to get up as close as
i could i thought it was gonna the car
was just gonna crane towards the group
that i was trying to stand behind and
they are escalating this whole thing the
one car lost its whole bumper and i
guess they picked it up and took it
uh they're they were crashing into each
other neighbors say this incident looked
organized with people using professional
cameras filming which is a commonality
with these racing groups who often post
their racing videos to youtube
we plan on continuing this story later
tonight so we will see if any street
racing takes place while we are out here
reporting in the northwest valley
madison kimbrough live local now